one update now on the former Vice
President Joe Biden he wasn't willing to
run against Trump in 2016 but now he
says he'd be happy to face the president
in the ring during an appearance the
University of Miami Biden said he'd be
able to beat up Trump watch when a guy
who ended up becoming our national
leader said I can grab a woman anywhere
and she likes it and then said I made a
mistake a mistake but they asked me what
I like to debate this gentleman and I
said no I said if we were in high school
I'd take you behind the gym and beat the
hell out of him I've been a lot of
wroclaw locker who's my whole life and
pretty damn good athlete any guy who
talked that way was usually the fattest
ugliest sob in the room is it tough man
that Joe Biden well this morning Trump
tweeted this in response crazy Joe Biden
is trying to act like a tough guy
actually he is weak both mentally and
physically and yet he threatens me for
the second time with physical assault he
doesn't know me but he would go down
fast and hard crying all the way don't
threaten people Joe president tweeted
that author and columnist mark Stein a
connoisseur of pugilism joins us tonight
so mark your job is to call this fight
what do you say I think on balance I I
probably give it to Trumbull though Joe
Biden is not to be underestimated
I understand that he swims naked in
front of his female Secret Service
agents most mornings which is not
something many 75 year-old men other
than Charlie Rose over at PBS would be
willing to do so he's obviously fairly
confident of his physique I don't
actually understand why he said oh if I
was still in high school I'd beat him up
because to my understanding of these
things Tucker if you're defending a
lady's honor isn't generally something
one associates with high school it's
it's something one would do after high
school as a grown man so I'm actually in
favor of physical violence between
individuals I'm in favor of dueling as
an alternative now I'm being I'm being
seriously I've been in
I'm stupid stuck in some stupid libel
suit in the District of Columbia for six
years I'd much rather have had pistols
at dawn over that and I think if these
two wanted to have a sword fight I would
be in favor of the reintroduction of
dueling I'm in favor of chivalry but
what Joe Biden teaches us I think is if
one is going to go in for male
braggadocio it required Trump is
actually harder to do than most people
think it requires a lighter touch and
there's something well the heavy-handed
about all is I've been in more I've been
in more locker rooms I've had more I've
been in around more guys I'm in more
round ugly mean ugly a so it requires
that kind of male take it from an effete
foreigner that kind of male watch this
requires a lighter touch well especially
when you're a I mean that's like that
one thing that Trump is indisputably
grabbe's a Viking so it's like you're
not going to beat about that but since
when is it okay for sensitive evolved
liberals like Joe Biden to all of a
sudden be threatening to beat people up
well I think this is what's fascinating
he's complaining about Trump because
from our you can grab a woman by the
whatever and they are and the
alternative to that is Joe Biden says
seize it is I hate guys who like to grab
women I like to beat guys up we like to
grab women and I noticed that on the
liberal websites and salan and all those
go they will say oh gosh
why isn't there some beta male pajama
boy around when you need one they're all
actually anti Biden for what he thinks
of as his chivalrous act of beating up
Donald Trump so I think the Liberals are
actually hopelessly confused that all
this the fact that you call it's a law
just made my night no matter what I'm
calling oh I'm I'm sorry about I've just
given my I've been in locker room such
rip your rip your lungs out that's how
gentlemanly I am the great Mark Steyn
thank you mark bags